me enseñaran que eeuu podría lograr todo
con trabajo y determinación y tener las
oportunidades para mí están limitadas
sólo por el tamaño de mi ambición que
debía soñar grande y eso hice window
esos sueños son los que me llevaron al
nueva york para que me quede aquí me
quieren igual si podía llegar allí podía
llegar a cualquier parte del mundo y eso
intentaba hacer pinter algún día no
hubiera imaginado que hoy estuviera en
este lugar
y que tuviera el apellido trump y
pichincha mi profesora de inglés me
decía no crean en todo lo que escuchan
sólo la mitad lo que leen esas palabras
no las entendía hasta que me conocí a mi
esposo de la familia trump es decir
cualquier idea que tenía antes de ellos
desapareció
ellos eran grandes trabajadores
y me recordaron a mi propia familia me
sintieron que estaban hicieron sentir
que estaba en casa trabajando la
organización trump vi ese mismo ambiente
familiar vi la cantidad de mujeres que
trabajaban allí sin derramar el género
no importaba lo que importaba era la
habilidad de hacer el trabajo y bueno yo
aprendí directamente con el 2016 mi mi
suegro me pidió que lo ayudara a ganar
en carolina del norte
aunque no tenía experiencia política
creyó en mí en whisky él sabía que yo
era capaz incluso si yo no lo sabía lo
que no me sorprende no me sorprendió con
el presidente de donald trump apoyo a
tantos mujeres en su gobierno la
secretaria de naciones unidos secretaria
y la primera mujer negra que ya tenía
muy frío y una gran cantidad de mujeres
en todo el gobierno
woolworth
fue contra el yen y 4.3 mil millones de
dólares de empleos se crearon
seis mil mujeres han salido de la
pobreza todos desde que asumió la
presidencia
esto no lo hizo para ganar votos hasta
lo hizo porque son las cosas que se
deben hacer
cien años atrás de la enmienda 19 fue
ratificada para permitirle voto a todas
las mujeres y desde entonces se han
hecho grandes logros por las mujeres en
eeuu desde el bolso park a salir
wright las mujeres a moldear la historia
de eeuu y la han hecho excepcional a
nivel mundial
me mira a mí misma mi juventud y miro
ahora lo que me digo ahora en la hora
que nos dirigimos a la elección más
crítica en la historia moderna esto no
es una elección
de republicanos y demócratas de entre
izquierda y derecha es una elección que
va a decidir si mantenemos a eeuu como
eeuu min ko si caemos en una camino del
socialismo
abraham lincoln dijo que eeuu nunca va a
ser destruida desde afuera se irán si
perdemos nuestra libertad será porque
nosotros mismos la destruimos
porque no con que esas palabras se
hicieron hace más de 150 años nunca han
sido más relevantes si escogemos el
camino de oportunidades de libertad y de
libertad que hacen este país el más
grande del mundo si mantenemos la
esperanza de aquellos que luchan la
opresión el comunismo y la tiranía no
sólo como un miembro de la familia trump
sino como una mujer que trabaja en dubai
y que aspira a seguir creciendo cuando
miro a mi hijo luke y a mi hija carolina
pienso que país le voy a dejar a ellos a
nuestras futuras generaciones
en los últimos meses hemos visto una
gran cantidad de políticos
y alentando a las manifestaciones
desmantelar la policía que es lo mejor
para el partido demócrata joe biden no
va a ser lo necesario para mantener el
orden para mantener seguros a nuestros
hijos en los vecindarios en las escuelas
para restaurar nuestra vida
estadounidense
no podremos soñar nuestros sueños
grandes por estar preocupados por la
seguridad de todos nosotros
aquí pero que se mantendrá eeuu sana y
segura
mantendrá eeuu prospera el presidente
camps va a mantener estados unidos como
eeuu están viendo y sin dudando de su
voto
no se dejen guiar por las noticias y
escuchen a alguien que lo sabe yo soy
del sur
escuchemos a escuelas públicas y trabaje
en un ies fueron a la universidad
estatal white mi profesora tenía razón
lo que aprendí
de nuestro presidente es diferente a lo
que ustedes han escuchado él es un buen
hombre él ama a su familia y que no
necesitaba este trabajo que nadie
trabaja tan fuerte por el pueblo
estadounidense que está dispuesto a
luchar por sus creencias por el pueblo
por el país que él ama y él es una
persona con convicción es un luchador y
no va a atenerse
davis es luchar por eeuu en hip hop para
proteger a nuestras familias y un inmune
débil afecta mucho a tener y nuestro
país no va a ser perfecto hasta que la
oportunidad de hacer equitativa para
todos incluidos especialmente las
mujeres estar en presidente ronald
reagan lo dijo lo mejor los sueños de
las personas difieren pero todos quieren
que sus sueños se hagan realidad ningún
eeuu ciudad nos da la oportunidad de
hacer eso
nosotros debemos hacer eso para nuestros
hijos y las futuras generaciones a mi
suegro gracias por creer en mí en
gracias por liderar este país y gracias
por seguir luchando cada día por eeuu
para que dios bendiga a todos los
estados que dios bendiga a las tropas y
que dios siga bendiciendo a este
increíble país
[Música]